most actors would probably love a chance
to score a role in HBO's Game of Thrones
and there have been plenty of a list
celebs who have tried to get on the hit
series to no avail but there was a time
when that wasn't the case whether it was
because of the grueling overseas filming
schedule gripes with the cast pay scale
or sheer confusion over the george RR
martin inspired story here's a look at
some actors who refused Game of Thrones
roles Tamzin merchant before Emilia
Clarke gained international fame as
Daenerys Targaryen Tamzin merchant was
originally cast as the mother of dragons
for the show's original unaired pilot
the first version of the pilot was
according to showrunners DB Weiss and
David Benioff a massive problem and 90%
had to be redone we had this great
opportunity when HBO decided to pick up
the series despite all the problems with
the pilot we got a chance to go back and
rewrite it when HBO reshot merchant
dropped out of the project for unknown
reasons and moved on to Salem opening
the door for Clarke to take over
Jennifer Ehle merchant wasn't the only
original Game of Thrones star to walk
away after its early problems Pride and
Prejudice star Jennifer Ehle was also in
the original pilots playing Catelyn
Stark but she too walked away after the
first take spelled trouble due to
unavailability for the reshoots she went
on to star in films such as The King's
Speech The Adjustment Bureau and zero
dark thirty
she also nabbed a part in the television
series a gifted man so her career hasn't
really been heard by her decision to
skip out on the role that ultimately
went to Michelle Fairley Jamie Campbell
Bower another actor featured in the
original pilot who had to drop out was
Jamie Campbell Bower the Twilight and
Harry Potter actor was originally cast
for the role of nights Watchmen weimar
Royce in the scratch pilots but became
unavailable once reshoots were scheduled
around the same time the actor was
starring in the small screen series
Camelot and readying for a lead role in
the Mortal Instruments so he was
replaced by robots leery it might not
have made much of a difference for his
career anyway since Royce was killed in
the show's opening scene maybe that was
an omen Brian Cox given his impressive
resume Scottish actor Brian Cox might
seem like a good fit
one of the Seven Kingdoms and somebody
on the show must have agreed he admitted
he was once offered a role early on but
turned it down over the lack of loot he
told Vaughn Zilla quote stupidly I
turned it down in the early days because
they didn't pay enough money now they
have more money and I was silly I was
silly it was silly because I'm a
complete addict now end quote
Cox admitted that he regrets missing out
on his chance especially since its
featured some of his old friends he
hopes he hasn't closed the door on that
opportunity for good quote I don't know
what I could play maybe I could do I
mean I just watched my friend Ian
McShane and I thought ooh Ian's in it so
I settled down to watch him and I
thought Ian did that and immediately I
thought God they must have paid him well
because I know Ian I'm still waiting for
the call for a game of Thrones and if
they've got more decent money I'll be
there and quote
hopefully they listen because seriously
no one wants to be on the receiving end
of an angry Brian Cox then you my friend
don't know crap about life and worried
off are you wasting my two precious
hours what you're moving Dominic West
while it's not quite known which Game of
Thrones role Dominic West was originally
courted for many suspect the affair star
may have been asked to appear as Mance
Rayder the former night's watchman who
became known as the king-beyond-the-wall
for his affiliation with the free folk
whatever the role though West told
Huffington Post in 2012 that he had to
decline the lovely part because of
family obligations quote I was offered
something on Game of Thrones and
unfortunately I hadn't seen it but my
nephew and his father said gosh Game of
Thrones is the only great show on and I
felt terrible because I just turned them
down it was a lovely part a good part
I'm going to regret it my problem is
I've got four kids and at the moment I'm
reluctant to be away from home for a
long time I can get a lot of work in
London and still be at home and quote
Gillian Anderson x-files star Gillian
Anderson also had to say no thanks to a
chance at Game of Thrones due to her
obligations as a parent she told stylus
magazine in 2013 quote whether it's Game
of Thrones or doubt Nabi
18 year old cannot believe I've turned
down things she loves but with a four
and six year olds I can't justify
spending that kind of time away from
home unless I'm working with Martin
Scorsese and quote while Anderson didn't
share which while she might have been
offered many speculate that due to her
famous red locks she may have been a
match for Melisandre the red which there
is someone I work with I like his name
is Jon Snow but I'm not really showing
you so my guy why not I am pretty sure
he's dead
Jonathan Pryce Game of Thrones fans will
undoubtedly recognize Jonathan Pryce as
the actor who portrayed the duplicitous
high Sparrow in seasons 5 and 6 but
believe it or not he was actually asked
to join the show long before that and
turned it down as he told BBC Radio 4
quote I'd said no to the very original
series of Game of Thrones and all I did
was flip through and look at the names
look on these strange names strange
dialogue and I thought oh it's not for
me end quote
what changed his mind he said was the
high sparrows personality and presence
quote high Sparrow it's a great
character he comes into the story
everyone's well established the goodies
and the baddies and they're all baddies
in some shape or form and high Sparrow
comes in as again quite relevant because
of the present Pope who presents himself
as a man of the people who will get down
washing their feet and stuff yet he is
this incredibly powerful figure who has
the wherewithal to dispense justice end
quote
Perdita weeks this one simply has to
hurt the tutors and Penny dreadful
actress Perdita weeks was originally
cast to star as Rosslyn Frey Edmure
Tully's wife but she backed out because
her commitment to another series called
the heretics required her to be on
location in Romania for six months one
problem the Romanian government refused
to let them film and the whole show got
scrapped anyway week's told The Daily
Mail in 2012 quote I gave up a role on
Game of Thrones to take the part and
even rang the producers to beg for it
back once I'd heard the news about
Romania but it was too late end quote
the role was ultimately played by
Alexandra doling although week's might
not have missed out on much the
character has appeared in just one
episode and was notably absent when her
husband returned in season 6 Ray
Stevenson
Irish native Ray Stevenson was also
given a chance to star in Game of
Thrones in its earliest episodes but he
told movies.com that he turned it down
because he was simply not into the TV
scene at the time and that he's not
willing to join it now since it's
already too developed at this point
quote I was offered a role
I also saw them before they even started
very early on I would rather have been
cast at the beginning I think it's
wonderful but it's not something I would
come into at this point I don't know if
I would add anything to it at this stage
I would rather have been involved in the
growth of a show even though everyone
gets bumped off left right and center I
kept seeing all the people I knew from
Rome in it but I can't man I can't
end quote given that Stephenson joined
both Dexter and black sails in progress
though it's possible he could still
change his mind
Lily Allen according to singer Lily
Allen she turned down the chance to star
in Game of Thrones opposite her
real-life brother Alfie Allen she would
have been Yara Greyjoy to his Theon
because of the ick factor associated
with the roles she wrote in a reddit AMA
in 2014
I've been asked to do a game of Thrones
cameo they asked me if I'd be interested
in playing Theon's sister and I felt
uncomfortable because it would have had
to go on a horse and he would have
touched me up and once they told me what
was entailed I said no thanks then again
she may have been pulling the Internet's
leg that time her brother himself later
came forward to dispel her claim telling
vulture that her words weren't true and
that Gemma Whelan was always the
original choice for the role thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to